[Música]
y con nuestro primer invitado del día
hablaremos de la crisis que están
atravesando las grandes compañías
tecnológicas tras crecer a velocidades
desorbitantes e impulsadas por la
pandemia escenarios como la guerra en
Ucrania cambiaron el panorama en 2022 se
produjeron unos 150.000 despidos algunos
de los más sonados son los 12.000 que
hubo en Microsoft u otros 12.000 en
Google 18.000 en meta 7500 en Twitter y
12.000 en Amazon frente a estos cambios
Qué pasará entonces con el mercado lo
analizamos con Álvaro Sánchez periodista
de economía del diario El País desde
Madrid Álvaro Gracias por estar con
nosotros y buenas tardes para usted
primero las tecnológicas crecieron a
ritmos desorbitantes beneficiadas por
los confinamientos de la pandemia
después hubo la guerra en Ucrania y este
Boom terminó de manera abrupta fallaron
en prever que el consumo no se podía
mantener virtual permanentemente
Buenas tardes Sí así ha sido hemos visto
que las plantillas de las tecnológicas
han crecido con mucha fuerza han pasado
de tener 900.000 empleados en 2017 a
tener prácticamente dos millones de
empleados Entonces ahora lo que estamos
viendo Es una corrección de ese error de
cálculo por qué porque las tecnológicas
pensaban que el tiempo de los
confinamientos donde todo el mundo
compraba más dispositivos Donde había
teletrabajo donde se compraba más por
comercio electrónico pues pensaban que
había llegado para quedarse y lo que se
está demostrando es que no es así los
ingresos están cayendo más los
beneficios están cayendo más entonces
están corrigiendo ese error de cálculo y
están despidiendo gente porque creen que
no van a poder mantener ese ritmo de
crecimiento que tenía antes por hacer
una comparación es como si los dueños de
los hoteles pensaran que siempre va a
ser temporada alta y se hubieran
dedicado a abrir hoteles y ahora se
dieron cuenta de que no de que no
siempre va a ser así y entonces los
cerraran bueno y el problema no solo
tiene que ver con un error de cálculo
sino también de publicidad que en medio
de todas las plataformas que existen
cada vez es más difícil hacerse notar
que otros ingresos A qué otros ingresos
pueden recurrir estas tecnológicas
Sí ahora por ejemplo Microsoft está
invirtiendo en Inteligencia artificial
para paliar un poco esos problemas que
está teniendo pero estamos viendo que
que bueno ha habido muchos problemas en
los ingresos publicitarios porque las
empresas están invirtiendo menos en
publicidad por culpa de la inflación que
está afectando a todos que los costes
energéticos están subiendo que con la
inflación la gente gasta menos eso hace
que ingresos de empresas como Amazon se
resientan mucho y bueno la realidad es
que están diversificándose hacia temas
como la robotización yo estuve en la
fábrica de Massachusetts de Amazon donde
están un poco enfocándose a crear robots
para ahorrar en empleo en salarios y
están un poco dirigiendo esos recursos
hacia la Inteligencia artificial y hacia
la robotización bueno tenemos entonces
un panorama que disminuye los ingresos
las empresas están recortando los
empleos para intentar estabilizarse Pero
cómo hacer entonces para lograr esos
objetivos sin la fuerza laboral
suficiente Y si la respuesta es esta que
usted acaba de decir la robotización
pues la teoría dice que con eso pueden
tener más productividad lo que está
claro es que estas empresas siguen
teniendo un músculo financiero
gigantesco cuatro de las cinco mayores
empresas del mundo son tecnológicas Y no
van a desaparecer tienen una crisis está
claro han caído en bolsa pero tienen
mucho músculo financiero para invertir
en todas estas nuevas tendencias
robotización Inteligencia artificial y
para generar más ingresos en eso
Entonces vamos a ver inversiones a lo
grande hacia este tipo de empresas como
ha hecho Microsoft el otro día con chat
gpt y bueno veremos si la jugada le sale
bien en el caso de Facebook por ejemplo
están invirtiendo mucho en el metaverso
y por ahora nos están viendo grandes
resultados son apuestas a veces
arriesgadas pero que bueno a largo plazo
les pueden salir bien también es el caso
de la nube por ejemplo que a Microsoft
le está dando ya una parte muy
importante de sus ingresos igual que
Amazon Bueno y qué están Y sobre todo
Qué tan utilizadas son estas tecnologías
como el metaverso o el chat gpt del que
usted nos hablaba
Pues todavía están en una fase bastante
incipiente
está por ver cómo se monetiza todo eso
porque
sabemos que tienen muchos usuarios y así
es como hizo por ejemplo Facebook
comprando WhatsApp no al comprar
WhatsApp en su momento no lo tenía
monetizado pero luego encuentran formas
de monetizarlas o no ese es el riesgo
asumen un riesgo pero todo el mundo
coincide que la Inteligencia artificial
va a ser fundamental en el futuro
entonces tienen equipos de expertos
suficientes como para pensar que tienen
que diversificar su negocio y dirigir
esas inversiones hacia allí y en un
punto de incertidumbre está clarísimo
bueno Y en medio de este declive
generalizado de las compañías
tecnológicas hay una excepción Apple
cuéntenos Por qué Apple no se está
afectando con los despidos masivos como
si está ocurriendo en las otras
compañías
Pues sí el caso de Apple que es la
empresa más valiosa del mundo en bolsa
es curioso porque por ahora es la única
que no ha despedido no podemos poner la
mano en el fuego de que no vaya a hacer
lo Próximamente pero por ahora se ha
mantenido así porque a la hora de
contratar fue mucho más prudente
mientras otras empresas ampliaban sus
plantillas mucho más rápidamente Apple
no lo hizo y bueno eso no quiere decir
que no hayan tenido una cierta crisis
porque con la política de covid Cero en
China muchas de las fábricas de Apple
estuvieron cerradas eso hizo que sus
componentes no llegaran a tiempo y que a
veces hubiera incluso falta de producto
en las tiendas y también han sufrido la
crisis de los semiconductores que bueno
con todo el aluvión de semiconductor es
que se pedían en la pandemia las
fábricas no daban abasto y no recibían
suficientes entonces Apple ha caído en
bolsa Pero ha caído menos que el resto
está resistiendo mejor y está
manteniendo su plantilla completamente
intacta eso no pueden decirlo ni
Facebook ni Amazon ni Google ni otras
europeas como Spotify por ejemplo que ha
sido una de las últimas en avisar de que
va a despedir a 600 trabajadores y cuál
es el panorama en este momento de Leo
semiconductores que son producidos
especialmente en Hong Kong y en Taiwán
que tanto suministro hay en el mundo
pues la realidad es que ha mejorado
bastante el suministro había unos
cuellos de botella muy muy fuertes pero
no se pueden descartar crisis futuras
ahora la realidad es que Europa y
Estados Unidos están invirtiendo
muchísimo muchísimo en tener sus propias
fábricas en su territorio porque se han
dado cuenta de que dependen
excesivamente de los que llegan de
Taiwán y de China o bueno o desde Asia
en general entonces ahora están
invirtiendo cantidades enormes en
tenerlos más cerca por si viene otra
crisis pero el problema es que esas
fábricas de semiconductores requieren
una alta tecnología llevan años a
hacerse llevan inversiones muy grandes y
no va a ser de un día para otro que
Europa y Estados Unidos sean
autosuficientes todavía hay dependencia
de Taiwán y la va a seguir habiendo y lo
que hay también es una guerra
tecnológica en marcha con china porque
Estados Unidos ha prohibido a China
importar Parte de algunos componentes
que son necesarios para que china
fabrique sus propios semiconductores
Entonces se puede decir que se ha
aliviado bastante la crisis que había en
la cadena de suministros que antes
impedía que muchos productos de Apple o
de o la PlayStation por ejemplo se
quedaran sin stock rápidamente pero
todavía en el futuro se pueden
reproducir problemas similares y sigue
habiendo problemas con los chips
relativos a los coches